you said eric posed the question at what
age is creepy right
clearly 47 24
they're they're good you said you dated
a guy 16 years older than you
it was fine it just didn't work out
you're saying that seven is the is a
magic number you're saying that eight
was the oldest you ever dated so what is
the line in your mind is there some
definitive line number the girl who told
me that there's 15 she goes i actually
like you but and i would go out with you
again i just don't see a future with you
because when you're 60 i'll be 45 and
you'll be old she's like i'm like you're
doing math 20 years down the road like
she's like yes because i want to get
married in the next few years i'm a
family i was like okay all right good
for you so is there a definitive line in
either you guys minds like all right
this is
the youngest or oldest guy i would date
i wouldn't serious i me personally i
wouldn't date a guy past like 50 plus oh
so 50 is the number for me personally
so you would get a date a guy double
your age
yeah oh wow not me no what's your number
probably like if i'm 28 right now about
40 would be max okay so like on your
tinder profile yeah you what do you have
it going up to
uh i deleted tinder first of all i
deleted all the apps as of like last
week no yes just because i'm done with
them but for that range i think i did
like 30 to 45.
oh you see you went up to 45
yeah because i'm in miami and the
experience of going on dates with like a
little bit older man is nice even if i'm
not looking to settle down is the older
the man is the more successful they have
to be meaning you'll date a 20
29 year old 30 year old who's kind of
figuring out their career but you're not
dating a 43 year old if he's [ __ ]
broke
do you understand what i'm saying here
the older a guy is that you're dating
the more successful they have to be yes
or no
i mean not that i wouldn't say that
statement because i've dated a guy who
was 25 and more successful than a guy
that was 30 okay but i'm saying if
you're getting that i don't mean like
that but like if you're going to date a
guy significantly older this is general
no he has to ha he has to be established
like he has to i think establishes a
better word than successful because i
think it's like what is established
versus successful somebody who's
grounded who's who knows their plan even
if they're not making millions or they
don't they've got it figured out and
they're hustling and they have energy
and they're like
they've got some some [ __ ] figured out
how much money a year is established
uh
hmm
between 50 to 60 like as a minimum 50
50k
so so 40 years old 50k a year minimum
minimum that's very what about you jenny
somewhat established yes that's very um
that's not low but that's that's just
median income in america there's nothing
does he have a car does he have a house
does he have anything
easy on the car stuff jenny
yeah is he doing that i'm sorry miami
i'm not taking my kids and ubers
everywhere i go okay say i've ever heard
that of course okay okay but go ahead
what were you saying does he got a car
they're saying you're saying what is
established how much eric asked how much
money a year yeah but i'm saying i mean
he could be 50k but still living at home
so
what are we talking about i love when
jenny gets a little latina fiery that's
like because you guys are so quick to
ask questions without context and it's
like there's more than just that one
question get it together honestly you're
gonna cancel culture asap
um
okay so what do you think happens here
with leo and this girl camila based on
his track record he's probably going to
cut her off by the time the 25 year old
milk expiration thing happens what do
you think because she's going to be 25
in the next few months so we'll we will
revisit this give a prediction i think
you'll stay with her you think so
now you think it's cutting off yeah
all right well
leo we wish you the best you're a
freaking stud uh keep
keep doing you bro hold out hold out set
the bar high and uh
keep uh yeah his track record is pretty
impressive derek jeter that's another
guy if you know derek jeter baseball
she loves derek jeter he was the same
thing as leo
he finally settled down now he's a
married man established george clooney
he did it longer than anybody he found a
woman who is
not only attractive but is a a game
changer in the legal world and she's
bringing a lot to the table his age
range
i mean age range i don't i mean no he's
60 years old i think she's probably
i would have guessed my age i don't know
but they're doing great but basically
guys you know eventually want
the same one yes every every day i'll
tell you one last piece and then i want
to get your opinion on something else i
remember
being this is when i used to be in the
nightlife business um in my early 20s
and before i got into finance i remember
looking across the club
there was a major major club promoter
at the time
he's still around he has a bunch of
pizza shops in south beach
and i remember he was kind of like
a little bit chubbier he was balding he
was kind of letting himself go a little
bit it was a tuesday night he was out in
the club arguing with his girl on a
tuesday night in south beach i was
probably 24 at the time 25 he was
probably 44 or 45
and i looked at him and i said i'm never
going to be this guy i'm never going to
be that dude 45 years old in the club
promoting you know dad botting it up and
not uh it's just that's you have to make
a change